9月8號,OpenAI宣佈用一萬個agent解掉了懸賞一百萬美元的千禧年難題Navier Stokes。
一直在逼近這一題的是紐約大學Current研究所的數學教授Tristan Buckmaster。
他研究流體方程的起義點,已經六七年,合作者Levent Alpog在Anthropic上班。
OpenAI宣佈之前,他跟OpenAI的人通了一通視訊電話。
這是數學頻道Numberphile9月底上架的專訪。
他從頭講內通電話,也講數學界為什麼開始不敢公開自己的未解問題。
你笑著笑著,
這就讓我想問的第一個問題,
你現在是如何感覺?
比幾個月前更好。
我說,我仍然仍然,我仍然沒有穩定,但確實,你知道,我說,
在那一星期中
我有一個兩個月的寶寶
每個星期都會發生的事
我通常會睡兩小時
有些人會一直打開我辦公室的門
有時候門會打開
我會睡在桌子上
我真的太累了
你感覺到你被10,000名業務人員騙了你嗎?
你感覺到你被騙了什麼?
從你的看法
是的,我就是
我就是很愚蠢
我就是
你知道,我不是
我是一個他
的那種
文化
你知道,因為
我
已經
在
談論
我
有這種
我之前曾經與Google DeepMind合作
所以我認識了科技企業中如何運作
我認識了基本上任何事情都可以
所以我認識了
你懂的
你懂的,理論是移動快,破壞東西
你懂的,那種理論與數學合作
你這個時候被破壞了嗎
是的,我說,有趣的是,我,你知道,我只是
,它可能是這麼簡單的,對嗎?如果他們只是玩他們的卡,
他們應該玩的那樣,然後他們讓我們發佈結果,
然後他們,你知道,發佈了他們的海洋,然後他們有,
你知道,然後路線會更清楚,然後故事會更清楚,
他們就能夠解決納比亞斯托克的問題
勒萬德是為了安卓比克工作的
但這是他的外部項目
他和我一起工作
這並不是一項多億美元的
安卓比克項目
當然,就像達里奧說的
讓我們打開智能
然後會有一個不同的故事
但這並不是這樣的
我們從來都不想這樣的
他們只是讓我們把結果發佈
然後就這樣做
And then they would have got the
nothing would have been such a big drama
他跟Aupog先做出來的是Oiler方程
可以想成少了粘性的Navier Stokes
他說真正的機制就在Oiler裡
他自己用AI好幾年了
Aupog還搭了一整套agent系統
外界以為把題目貼進去
按下Enter就有答案
他說那正是AI公司想賣的印象
Oiler的結果還沒發表
消息就先傳了出去
Anthropic是要解決1億元的價值
我認為傳聞是Anthropic解決了2億元價值的價值
這就是我們工作的價值
但這就是錯誤的
傳聞是錯誤的
因為說我們沒有解決納利斯特克
我們解決了油價
原來的傳聞只是說他們不能解決Anthropic
然後他們發現它是Levent
主持人先插了一個問題
OpenAI後來發的那篇證明
到底算不算解說來了
它們可以成為數學學家接受的東西
我們曾經遭遇一個謠言
我們已經解決了納比薩克斯問題
當時情況變得有點瘋狂
我與一名數學學家通過開放智能
解決了問題
他最初回應說
我跟他們說,
我們不想競爭,
我們很高興
我還跟他們說,我們也在使用你們的產品
我們還在寫文章,
我說我們下週見面
我說,然後我們獲得了這個信息,從數學家來說,
那我們正在做一個很愚蠢的事情,那是他們說的,
我們不知道那是什麼,但是我們,
我說,你可以做任何你喜歡說的話的假設,
但是像我說的,
我正在做一個很愚蠢的事情,
你需要與我們打個電話,
那是在星期天,
但是,但傻-似乎像是傻的,在那些
context 的那種疑惑中,你知道,這不只
像是傻,就是傻,就是傻,不是
不,是的,不是傻,就是傻,不
像是傻,就是傻,就是傻,
那他們正在做
一些非常非法的事,
所以你真的就要這個,你就要
以為不是說,我們正在做
一些普通的、神奇的
事情,你就體會了,我們正在
做些我們不應該做的事情
,絕對是,是的,
我們就以為他們正在
要做一件很糟糕的事情
你必須在通訊中解決這件事
訊息裡沒說那件事是什麼
他猜
OpenAI大概是想搶在他們前面發表
他跟LPOG那幾篇結果
用的都是加外力的做法
所以我才在通訊中解決
是他們告訴你解決了嗎
還是他們還沒解決
我猜
Sebastian有
我猜可能
我不記得
我記得他們告訴我們,
他們在電話開始解決它,
但我認為,
如果我記得正確的話,
他可能在電話裡提到,
像在電話前幾分鐘前,
好的,
然後我發現的第一個問題是,
他們解決了哪個問題?
對,因為它們有不同的解決方法,它們有不同的,有幾個不同的結尾線,
所以你只是從技術角度來看,你只是很驚訝
其實不是,我不是很驚訝
我只是想知道他們是否用了我們的方法
因為如果他們是用了強迫的方法
那就代表他們是用了強迫的方法
而且他們是用了強迫的方法
最初他們是騙人的
所以他們第一次來電話的時候,
他們準備好了這些東西,
這並不是他們只是混亂了,
而是他們準備好了,
他們想向我們展示計劃。
在這個時候,我認為他們正在騙,因為他們之前騙了計劃用來解決其他數學問題。
但是那些數學家在屏幕上顯示我,
所以我認為這是一個Google Meet的會議,
他們顯示在屏幕上顯示我,
他們簡直是複雜了萬億獎項目的問題。
他們說他們拿了獎項,按進去,然後他們得到了解決方案。
我當時就笑了,因為這真是太愚蠢了。
在幾分鐘之內,我發現這是一個謊言。
他們之前有做過其他問題。
他們提供了其他提示。
這些謊言在幾分鐘之內消失了。
但這就是他們準備給我的東西。
他們也不會告訴我他們開始工作的時間。
我一直問他們,你開始工作的時間是什麼時候?
他們說,我們有這些厲害的模型。
我們有這些厲害的模型。
我不是一些...
我 driving the field
that understands how this works
and understand that model is one thing
like the number of agents
and stuff like that
there is more to the story there
and eventually I said
I sort of did a loaded question
to Sebastian, I said
So you agree
that you only started working on it
after the rumor
and he said Yes
I mean there's no law against
如果我聽到有人說要做一個我正在做的YouTube視頻
我應該也會把我的視頻放在XpressPath上
所以我會先進去
但你有沒有任何的知識或信心
認為你用OpenAI、Codex進行的東西
是用OpenAI的
無論是直接看它
還是用來訓練模型
我認為這並不是很大的區別,但我認為是什麼,你認為是什麼,或者你認為是什麼?
所以,
你知道,
我不能完全證明什麼正在發生的,
但是狀況證據很明顯。
所以,
每個人都一直指向納維亞·斯托克問題和我們的工作相比,
但這並不是正確的文章。
比較正確的紙,比較正確的紙是
歐爾勒規則,現在歐爾勒規則的
歐爾勒規則的所有
機制在這個歐爾勒規則中
相似於我們還沒有發佈的
不同版本的紙,就像他們
自己根據我們發佈的所有
紙的所有想法
,我認為
從歐爾勒規則到歐爾勒規則
實際上是很小的
基本上
所有建築物的主要材料
在那種不被迫使用的
OILER中
都在我們的工作中
他們在他們的設備上
而且並沒有被公佈
並沒有被公佈
而最重要的事情是
在Navistar的問題上
他們使用了10,000個人
他們沒有使用10,000個人
他們使用了100個人,
所以他們從完全沒有用到的東西,
只用了100個人。
這個數量是很重要的,因為數量代表了你能夠搜索的距離。
他們使用了100個人,結果他們的建築物和我們的建築物是一樣的。
你對他們使用的產品感到羨慕嗎?
因為你認識這個企業,你自己說你認識這個企業,你認識它們的工作方式。
您是否犯了一個錯誤,把所有這些東西都放在Codex上?
您是否忽略了?您會再做嗎?
是的,我們做了很多錯誤。
我認為,你認為,有一個錯誤,
在第一個位置發生了什麼破壞。
我認為,你認為,有很多人,
你認為,有沒有發生過破壞,
他們就不會有這個紅燈。
我認為,我從來沒有使用Codex。
絕對的。
你認為,是的,我認為我們是。
I didn't think that
OpenAI研究長Mark Chin公開說過,沒有人也沒有AI去翻過使用者的資料
官方聲明另外補了一句,
雖然不太可能,
但無法排除他們用產品留下的資料,
在去掉身份之後幫模型變強過
主持人接著問他,要不是合作者在Anthropic上班,他是不是會分到更多功勞
我想再推返一下借費的問題,
因為我不是有更多借費的工作,
我只是不喜歡我正在努力推返的事情,
因為在這些公司的行業的文化中,
這些公司的行業的行業是對數學社會有很大的影響。
所以我並不在乎取得更多金額,
我並不在乎取得金額
問題是,這些研究室之間的超級競爭
我應該說,這些研究室不是唯一的研究室
曾經花了億多美元解決Navia Strokes的問題
主持人替另一邊說話
撇開禮貌不談
這題本來可能還要再等幾十年
OpenAI一下子就解掉了
對數學不也是好事嗎
10月20日,世界就不會改變。
現在,數學社區的影響有巨大的影響,
因為現在每個人都不想談論他們的開放問題。
人們擔心這些AI公司會突然進來,
並且將它們視為標準問題。
人們不相信這些智能產品的任何東西
它對學術有很大的影響
因為這些智能研究室對我們有很大的威脅
所以它對科學進展有很大的影響
一切都在於準備準備結果幾個星期前
我喜歡亞洲冠軍獎項目
但是這並不是治療癌症
並且解決了亞洲冠軍獎項目
例如8月或20月
這將毫無影響世界
您在這裡做了什麼
您願意對人們說話
就像我一樣
您做了公開的說明
這是一個巨大的富裕公司
有很多力量和資源
這對你來說是一個很難決定的決定嗎
以這方面來說
你很容易會走到另一個方向
你對這些影響有什麼想法
還是這對你來說是自然的
我被邀請
作為他們的唯一作者
寫作的機會
然後將我的合作人員
扔下車上
主持人最後丟了一個假設
如果是日本有一組數學家
跟他走在同一條路上
他聽到風聲就踩油門
搶先發表
這跟OpenAI有什麼不一樣?
但,你知道,這並不會是,但我相信這不是發生的,如果他們進入,我
不,我說他們說他們沒有,你知道嗎,但是如果他們進入了
Codex 和像你把你的工作拿出來,你把你放在那裡在信心上,
就像你擁有你的手袋,是的,那就是,那就是,那就是為什麼我生氣
,好,我只是想清楚,因為我不知道他們會否跟著我說,他們說
他們會批評,他們公開批評了許多次,我會鏈接到,這並不是他們做的事。
絕對的,但他們還說他們在納比亞·斯托克的一項目標。
這將會改變你作為一個數學學者的方式嗎?
肯定會改變你使用的Codex。
So nothing important goes into Codex
So nothing of any actual value
他說這一題9月8號或9月20號解出來
對世界沒有差別
受傷的是數學界
大家開始不敢公開自己的未解問題
他自己的做法是重要的想法
再也不放進Codex
原影片46分鐘
他還講了OpenAI那篇證明到底聰明在哪
他說從Oiler跳到Navier Stokes的那一步是好點子
用的正是他自己試了十多年都沒做成的方法
還有他13歲就在用GPU寫電腦繪圖引擎
本來想當遊戲工程師
是當數學家的叔叔把他拉進數學
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多